[Applause]
[Music]
we made it guys it's been another great
year for new releases and one of the
best years for video games ever we're
closing out 2017 with a look at what the
rest of December brings if you haven't
sent your list off to Santa yet you
might find some new requests here some
of these games are nice and some are
definitely naughty
some of them are also inner Galactic
like curse of Osiris the first expansion
for destiny 2 sends guardians to mercury
to rescue Osiris himself from the vex
expect the usual new guns in gear but
mercury is also home to some unique
locations like the infinite forest which
will be different every time you jump in
new crucible Maps strikes and the first
raid layers will also be deployed
cursive Osiris comes to all platforms
destiny to is on that's ps4 Xbox one and
PC on Tuesday December 5th we've also
got a look at some mercury free roaming
public events and one of the best new
weapons if you want to take a look ahead
of time next up is Dead Rising for
Frank's big package which is definitely
part of the naughty list as the
suggestive name implies this version
includes the base game and all
previously released DLC costumes and
weapons
plus a new Capcom Heroes mode that lets
Frank dress up as characters from Street
Fighter Megaman and more did I mention
it's also the game's debut on ps4 that
too the package will be delivered on
Tuesday the fifth also on the naughty
list is hello neighbor and chances are
you haven't played anything quite like
it you've just moved into a new house
and a creepy neighbor seems to be up to
no good cue the stealth horror gameplay
of you sneaking around trying to figure
out what your neighbor might be hiding
at least until he catches you hello
neighbor has been playable for a while
now but the full version comes to Xbox
one and PC on Friday December 8th I'm
just hoping the first expansion includes
mr. Rogers
please won't you be my neighbourhood now
let's roll onto the nice list with local
Rotary master'd if you've played the
original then you'll enjoy the same
tilting and bouncing gameplay as before
now in HD all the way up to 4k if you've
got a ps4 Pro if it's your first time
playing prepare for a cutesy adventure
with lots of little yellow glob dudes
bouncy levels and great music you can
give it a whirl on ps4 on Saturday
December 9th finishing off the nice list
and closing out the year is one more
remake Okami HD again if you've played
it before expect the same zelda like
adventure starring the wolf goddess of
the Sun but it'll look better than ever
on the latest console generation it also
includes that lovely 4k support if
you're rocking an Xbox one or ps4 Pro
either way it's coming to those
platforms plus PC on Tuesday December
12th and those are some of the hottest
games we'll be playing to close out the
year as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys new releases is going into
hibernation until the new year so I'll
see you all back here in January to talk
about the big games of 2018